moi j'ai appelé à manifester mais à
manifester non pas contre eric zemmour
mais pour les valeurs que nous défendons
et c'est pour ça qu'ils récusent zemmour
n'est pas le bienvenu à montreux du
point de vue des valeurs je vous donne
deux exemples en 1944 place de l'hôtel
de ville saint manouche qui a mis le
drapeau bleu-blanc-rouge sur l'hôtel de
ville je vous donne un deuxième exemple
il ya une femme qui viennent quitté
montreuil qui a plus de 70 ans elle
s'appelle madame zone aussi une
italienne elle retourne au pays et juste
avant de quitter elle a tenu à nous
donner sa maison qui vaut beaucoup de
sous et elle nous a dit la mairie vous
allez faire une chose vous allez faire
en sorte que cette maison elles servent
à aider de pauvres gens elles servent à
aider des gens qui en ont besoin et donc
moi quand j'ai vu sur les médias bfm tv
qui disait eric zemmour venir à
montreuil j'ai reçu plein de gens qui
qui m'ont dit il faut compte défendre
nos valeurs il faut qu'on dise ce qu'on
est alors vous le savez depuis longtemps
patrice bessac que j'ai eu voilà d'aider
des gens de belles femmes aujourd'hui le
patron de bfm
il vous le savez depuis que quinze jours
trois semaines et où tout était si tout
était bouclé il ya même des mails il ya
des échanges de mails en moi je l' ai
appris à trois jours quand vous mais
tous les organisateurs et le ca innocent
en fait payer un jour regarde moi je l'
ai appris à trois jours et en fait les
organisateurs ils ont été contactés par
bfmtv ils ont raconté ensuite la bfm tv
leur a pas dit pourquoi c'était alors
c'est parce qu'on m'a dit j'ai eu
vraiment il ya même des échanges de
mails où ils disent voilà c'est pour
venir avec eric zemmour lui même il
avait même choisi la salle et que sais
tu pas dans le secret leur conversation
je dise que l'association a dit et une
fois que bfmtv leur a dit c'est pour
l'émission d'eric zemmour cette
association qui fait du soutien aux
jeunes entrepreneurs de l'intégration du
travail de de développement écologique
qui travaillent dans le domaine culturel
a dit c'est pas mes valeurs et moi je
les comprends parce que comme maire de
montreuil franchement j'ai pas envie de
mettre un kopeck et de donner des moyens
pour accueillir eric zemmour mais c'est
une question
pardon vous vous avez dit que vous
connaissez montreuil vous voyez comment
naît c'est à dire dans toutes les rues
dans toutes les rues il ya des gens de
toutes conditions d'une gestion mais
juste monsieur le maire est ce que vous
pensez pas que ça c'est une noria un
accro à la démocratie franchement c'est
pourquoi aujourd'hui je pouvais pas dire
la ville m'appartient je n'ai pas le
droit mais les pas envie d'avoir eric
zemmour mais le radar de la voilà cinq
ans dit dallas est essentielle si je
puis me permit nous permettre je n'ai
pas dit que je voulais lui interdire de
venir oui qui n'est pas bienvenu moi
j'aime y est créé comme moi j'ai mime
moi j'ai mis mon combat sur le terrain
des valeurs dans le comprends votre
combat tout est à dire eux mais à la
manifestation qu'il y aura en mairie
mercredi prochain vous a rappelé à la
manifestation ap la manifestation non
pas contre eric zemmour mais pour qu'on
montre qu'on appelle la presse qu'on
diable tout le monde voilà ce qu'il fait
à montreuil chose voilà je mets mes en
juste juste parti au psg ou pas la même
chose mais ça me choque la même chose de
rentrer dans un climat de violence et de
haine ou alors d'avoir envie de défendre
non seulement les journalistes de bfm
qui font un travail formidable qui ont
tout préparé voilà la direction de bfm
aussi vous avez conscience que vous les
pénaliser non mais moi je n'y suis pour
rien dans
la il a forcément elle va pas elle va
pas se faire la malle émission c'est
trop compliqué mais moi je n'y suis pour
rien ce que j'ai juste dit c'est ce que
je pense parce que franchement moi je
suis maire j'y passe quasiment toute ma
vie mais comme meyrin tout le boulot
c'est de réunir faire en sorte que les
gens se parlent travaillent ensemble
créé des choses et c'est franchement il
ya un débat aujourd'hui qui est un débat
présidentiel qui est un débat que moi
j'appelle de violence et de mort pour le
pays on peut débat qui un débat qui fait
qu' on pousse à l'agressivité partout or
moi franchement on a fait des concerts
de la mairie ces
manifestations nous s'en sortir alors on
va voir la vidéo mais cela donne un
temps sera martin qui jour après jour
vous allez nous avait un gars qui a été
fait vraiment bon au moment où les où il
ya eu les attentats de charlie hebdo
j'ai appelé à une manifestation il ya eu
des milliers de gens toutes les
communautés religieuses représentées
devant la place de la mairie donc si
parfois c'est pas ta mère appelle à
défendre des valeurs